bonsoir nous sommes le 19 mai bienvenue
pour ce nouveau journal de la rédaction
de TV fil voici les principaux titres un
peu plus de 21 % de grvistes aujourd'hui
la mobilisation des enseignants des
collèges moins élevés dans les Yvelines
que dans le reste de la France il
dénonçaiit la réforme présentée par la
ministre Naj valau Belkassem la suite de
notre semaine consacrée aux ivelinois
présents à can pour le festival toujours
en partenariat avec Radio sensation vous
ferez la connaissance tout à l'heure
d'un cinéphil qui ne manque aucune
projection et puis invité de cette
édition romain vaayer délégué local de
l'Union Française de la santé des pieds
alors que la 13e édition de la Journée
nationale de prévention va se dérouler
dans quelques jours 65 % des Français
souffrent de leur pied 33 % d'entre nous
ont des pathologie qui nécessite la
consultation d'un podologue cette
agression violente d'automobiliste par
de faux policiers en moins de 10 jours
sur le département des Yvelines le
directeur départemental de la sécurité
publique annonce la mise en place d'une
cellule spéciale d'enquête il appelle
également la vigilance le mode
opératoire est à chaque fois identique
les faux policiers utilisent un
girophare pour forcer les véhicules à
s'arrêter sur le bas côté avant d'avoir
recours à la force voiture de gros
cylindré et fourgon utilitaire sont
principalement ciblé les syndicats
représentatif de la grande majorité des
enseignants ont donc appelé à manifester
ce mardi contre la réforme des collèges
ils craent notamment une inégalité entre
les établissements dans les ivblines
selon le rectorat un peu plus de 21 %
des enseignants étaient en grève querine
zulato pour les
précisions Cécile buff est conseillère
principale d'éducation ce mardi midi
elle prenait le départ pour la
manifestation parisienne pour cette CPE
du Collège Albert Einstein de Manil et
amamoau la réforme des collèges proposée
par la ministre Najat valobelkassem pose
des inquiétudes réelle et forte
notamment en ce qui concerne la
définition des programmes vu par cycle
et non plus par annésolaire jusqu'à
présent un élève de collège bénéficiit
de ce qu'on appelle une grille horaire
et des programmes nationaux actuellement
avec le projet présenté par la ministre
on n'est plus du tout sur cette logique
là nous sommes sur des horaires définis
par cycle ce qui va poser de sérieux
problèmes si un élève change
d'établissement admettons que il soit
dans un établissement a dans lequel on
est décidé d'étudier les pourcentages en
classe de 4e il déménage pendant les
vacances d'été pour se rendre dans un
collège B dans lequel il a a été décidé
d'étudier les pourcentages en classe de
5e au final cet élève n'aura jamais
étudié les pourcentages on voit
disparaître des des des horaires fléchés
pour l'enseignement des langues
anciennes pour les classes européennes
pour les classes bilangues autre
inquiétude l'autonomie accrue des
collèges 20 % des dotations horaires
pourrai être attribué par le conseil
d'administration des établissements on
se retrouve vraiment sur une éducation
définie localement dans le cadre du
projet d'établissement qui est propre à
chaque établissement il y a 5000
collèges en France ça représente 5000
manières de fonctionner il faut une
réforme du collège on n peut plus de
travailler comme on travaille on n peut
plus d'être obligé de réapprendre à lire
écrire et compter à des élèves de 6e
alors qu'ils sont 28 30 par classe oui
il faut une réforme diminuons les
effectifs mettons des enseignants devant
les élèves formons les enseignants foo
fait partie des six syndicats avoir
appelé à se mobiliser dans les Yvelines
le rectorat annonce 21,31 %
d'enseignement grevistes dans les
collèges publics c'est 6 points de moins
qu'au plan national une réforme appuyé
par le président Hollande il était
d'ailleurs venu il y a 10 jours au
Mureau soutenir sa ministre de
tutelle et cette réforme des collèges
est-ce une bon bonne idée selon vous
c'est notre question du jour micro
trottoir vos réponses j'ai entendu aussi
qu'il voulait supprimer le latin et ça
je trouve que c'est un peu dommage euh
même si ça peut sembler parfois élitiste
ça concourt quand
même à la culture général les langues
mortes c'est peut-être moins
indispensable mais après tout si
certaines personnes en ont envie
pourquoi les supprimer aussi hein le
latin c'est très important surtout pour
les élèves qui veulent faire la le
lettre c'est très important mais pour
les gens qui veulent faire l'économie
c'est pas vraiment du tout important ah
les langues B ça je j'ai j'ai moins
d'avis le latin j' pas fait donc je
pense qu'on peut s'en passer mais bon
les langues c'est c'est un autre
problème je n'y suis pas du tout
favorable puisque je suis enseignante en
fait jusqu'ici on avait 3 He en 4e 3h en
3e et maintenant on va avoir exactement
le volume horaire mais étalé sur euh sur
3 ans à mon avis c'est pas du tout
positif le 10 avril a donc été adopté
par le Conseil supérieur de l'éducation
la nouvelle réforme du collège avec
celle-ci un nouveau programme qui doit
être mis en œuvre pour cette rentrée
2016 faut-il s'en inquiéter c'est le
thème du 78 sociétés à suivre juste
après ce journal ce mardi 65 % des
Français souffrent de leur pied 33 %
d'entre nous ont des mots et des
pathologies qui nécessitent
impérativement la consultation d'un
podologogue des chiffres annoncés par
l'Union française pour la santé des
pieds romain vaillur bonsoir euh vous en
vous en êtes l'un des délégués délégués
de l'Association au niveau départemental
et pédicure podologue également quelles
sont les premières personnes qui sont
concernées ce sont les sportifs les
adolescents est-ce qu'il y a une
population qui est à risque alors
l'ensemble de la population est
concernée des enfants aux personnes
âgées en passant par le sportif la femme
enceinte ou la personne lambda
adolescent adulte voilà ça touche tout
le monde après ces différentes
pathologies bien entendu qu'on pourrait
développer l'enfant la scoliose
déformation du pied déformation d'orteil
les personnes âgées qui ont des
difficultés à se couper les ongles voilà
qus sont les problèmes néanmoins les
plus les plus récurrents les plus
récurrentson forcément la personne
consulte pour une douleur à la base donc
elle vient pour une douleur donc il faut
répondre à cette attente donc après on a
tout un arsenal thérapeutique pour
répondre à cette à cette demande
l'enfant lui présente moins de douleur
donc lui ça va plus à des déformations
c'est l'alarmation des parents les
parents s'alarmment il a les pieds en
dents il a les genoux déformés et là du
coup faut répondre à cette demande et on
travaille bien sûr en parallèle avec des
kinésithérapeutes des ostéopathes et on
propose nos traitements s'agissant des
personnes diabétiques néanmoins là la
consultation est indispensable on va le
rappeler avant de parler des autres
catégories de population mais sur les
personnes diabétiques c'est assez
spécifi pour les diabétiques c'est très
spécifique donc d'une part ils sont pris
en charge par l'Assurance Maladie donc
en fonction du grade on grade le risque
donc le risque c'est une amputation une
plie qui s'agrafee qui s'infect qui
amène à amputation donc pour éviter ça
on a des soins de prévention alors
premièrement euh pour les personnes à
plus à risque c'està-dire qui ont
neuropathie c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont une
perte de sensibilité le sang circule mal
il y a une artériopathie des membres
inférieurs il y a une prise en charge 4
soins par an pour les grades 2 six fois
par an pour les grades 3 voilà je vais
pas rentrer dans le détail des grades
par que c'est compliquéou mais rappelez
qu'effectivement c'est important de
consulter de s'en inquiéter 21 mai se
déroulera la journée nationale pour la
santé du pied c'est la 13e édition
l'objectif vous l'avez compris c'est de
sensibiliser plusieurs opérations dans
le département 120 sites publics sont
concernés en France 150 sites scolaires
et entreprises également à travers le à
travers le pays dans le département il y
aura de deux rendez-vous qui sont prévus
deux rendez-vous sont prévus donc là
c'est la deuxème année on a deux deux
sites j'espère qu'on progressera dans
l'avenir donc on a un site à montela
jolie où là il y aura quatre podolog il
y en a quatre également à véisie la
particularité à mon la jolie c'est qu'on
aura des podologues du sport on aura de
l'analyse sur de la plateforme
baropodométrique c'est l'analyse des
pressions au sol du pied on aura
également une analyse par capteur donc
c'est de l'analyse d'amplitude
articulaire donc ça c'est plus axé sur
le sportif à véis il y aura qu podologu
également diagnostique pareil dans le
même dans la même optique pour les
diabétiques surtout test au
monophilament de la sensibilité teste
lespou enfin voilà pas mal de choses de
de prévu au programme et c'est ouvert à
tous pour ceux qui qui veulent consulter
quel bilan on peut faire des précédentes
éditions ne sera-ce que l'édition de
l'année dernière est-ce que justement
les gens qui sont venus vous voir
étaient des gens qui n'étaient jamais
all les consulter alors effectivement la
majeure partie des gens qui viennent
sont des personnes qui n'ont pas
consultter on a un observatoire national
c'estàd qu'on analyse on pose des
questions on a tout un interrogatoire
qu'on pose à chaque personne qui vient
et on remarque que seulement 30 % en
2012 consulter un podologue et
aujourd'hui on a 41 % donc sur 2 ans on
a une augmentation qui est assez
significative et en plus de ça on
remarque que les personnes qui portent
des semelles 64 % des personnes disent
être soulagé avec le port des semelles
pour différes pathologie et donc ça
c'est très intéressant de de souigner
peut-être pour souligner l'importance de
de cette opération annuelle de de
prévention de sensibilisation on peut
rappeler les conséquences d'une mauvaise
santé du pied bah les conséquences c'est
déjà dans un retentissement sur la vie
quotidienne une difficulté à se déplacer
à travailler c'est s de pas mal d'arrêts
de travail contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait penser il y a beaucoup d'arrêts
de travail pour des douleurs de pied N
et d'au qui pourrait être soulagé par le
P de Smel orthopédique et rien que ça
c'est c'est une part très très
importante et après il bien entendu la
cause sur le sportif qui oblige un arrêt
qui peut être plus long que que prévu et
et ensuite bah la vie quotidienne pour
pour tout le monde he ça veut dire que
la prévention aussi c'est important il
faut consulter assez jeunes la première
consultation c'est quoi vers 4 5 ans à
partir de 4 5 ans on peut commencer à
consulter voir avant s'il y a des
grosses déformations en général elles
sont prises en changement d'institution
dès 4 5 ans on peut commencer à
diagnostiquer des déformations on peut
suivre la scolose à l'adolescence c'est
là où c'est le plus important à partir
de 11 12 ans vraiment le suivi de la
scoliose est important et on rentre
vraiment dans ce schéma de traitement de
la scoliose euh voilà après on consulte
quand on a mal ou en prévention si on a
un doute h la prévention et puis
effectivement faire attention peut-être
pour les parents qui nous écoutent aux
chaussures que qu'on qu'on qu'on achète
pour les enfants ça aussi ça fait partie
la ch c'est c'est un c'est un grand
débat effectivement il faut bien la
choisir euh au jour d'aujourd'hui on a
un partenariat avec un magasin de
chaussures euh qui donne les critères
important du choix de la chaussure donc
nous on bien sûr on prodigue nos
conseils mais c'est intéressant de voir
qu'aujourd'hui les marchands de
chaussures s'intéressent à ça et qui
donne vraiment les critères de qualité
de la chaussure et pour l'enfant c'est
important avec une petite particularité
en regardant sur votre site justement
les les conseils de prévention qui sont
donnés aux parents et il est conseillé
de plutôt plutôt utiliser des des lacets
pour les chaussures des enfants faut
savoir qu'en milieu scolaire c'est pas
forcément ce qui est demandé parce que
ça complique la tâche des des
enseignants et des AD ça complique la
tâche mais c'estc le lacè qui permet de
bien régler le le serrage de la
chaussure que ce soit au niveau du cou
du pied ou en remontant plus au niveau
de la cheville et ça permet vraiment de
bien maintenir le pied et de pas
accentuer une déformation probable du
pied de l'enfant donc le ler plus que le
le scratch le c'est mieux après si le
scratch remonte suffisamment au niveau
de la fille il permet de bien tenir le
le coup de pied il y a pas de souci
c'est c'est aussi valable mais c'est
vrai que ça aide aussi l'enfant à
l'apprentissage du lassage pour le pour
la vie la vie adulte et puisqu'on donne
quelques conseil peut-être pour les
sportifs qui vont se redécouvrir avec le
retour des des beaux jours là aussi il
faut faire attention ça semble une
viidance mais mais quelquefois en raison
du budget on fait peut-être des
économies et qui peuvent coûter pour la
santé ensuite oui il faut surtout pas
faire d'économie sur la chaussure après
le prix n'est pas forcément un critère
de choix objectif he il y a des
chaussures très cherres qui sont de très
mauvaise qualité vaut mieux aller dans
des magins spécialisés prendre conseil
au niveau du podologue un podologue du
sport forcément sera sera mieux mieux
informé sur sur les chaussures après il
y a énormément de types de chaussures
sur le marché avec des hauteurs de talon
très différentes aujourd'hui la mode est
pas mal au minimaliste minimaliste faut
savoir c'est quelque chose de très très
particulier qui est réservé à des
sportifs qui sont aguéris et qui peuvent
courir sans sans amorti au niveau du
talon voilà pour les les quelques
conseils qu'on peut donner rapidement ce
soir mais comment vous expliquez que
globalement on se soucie peu de la santé
du pied que ça fasse pas partie de la
prévention alors que le dentiste c'est
rentré dans les murs tout le monde sait
qu'il faut consulter faire attention
même anticiper les les éventuels
problèmes pas pour le pied le pied d'une
part tout le monde les cache en général
on veut pas les montrer un pied c'est
pas beau c'est vraiment ce que dit ce
que dit tout le monde en général dans
les consult ation en plus de ça les
sances sont pas remboursé ou très mal
donc ça c'est vraiment un frein dans
dans la prévention au jour d'aujourd'hui
et le but de la journée c'est vraiment
d'ouvrir ça de de de casser un peu les
TOU par qu'il y a vraiment un tou autour
du pied et de montrer qu'il faut s'en
soucier par que c'est vraiment à
l'origine de beaucoup beaucoup de
pathologies du côté du remboursement
justement est-ce que vous faites partie
de ceux qui militai pour avoir un
meilleur remboursement une meilleure
prise en charge on milite après avec le
syndicat avec l'Ordre national c'est
difficile aujourd'hui ces priode de
vache maigre avec la sécurité
social on a obtenu déjà le remboursement
pour les diabétiques ce qui est pas mal
ce qui serait bien ce serait de
l'étendre à tous les diabétiques comme
on l'a dit tous les diabétiques sont pas
remboursé au jour d'aujourd'hui ça pose
vraiment problème les smells sont un
petit peu remboursés mais les mutuels
remboursent commencent vraiment à bien
rembourser les smells et commencent
aussi à prendre en charge les soins de
pédicurie il faut se renseigner auprès
de sa mutuel et pas hésiter à prendre un
forfait avec deux ou tris séances par an
c'est vraiment intéressant ça coûte cher
de prendre soin de de ses pieds de la
santé des pieds ça coûte cher si on est
bien couvert par une mutuelle non si on
est est pas bien couvert et qu'on a
besoin de consulter tous les mois oui ça
peut coûter cher mais le rendu est
vraiment vraiment bénéfique quand on en
arrêt de travail on a la moitié des
salaires qui part voilà donc si on
soigne juste les les pieds en une séance
on peut revenir au travail euh voilà on
est on est gagnant et puis il y a cette
journée de prévention journée nationale
et là ce sera gratuit pour les
différentes consultations qui sont
organisées dans le département il y a
deux rendez-vous je vous les redonne du
côté de mante la jolie et puis du côté
de véisie également c'est la 13e édition
au niveau national de cette journée de
de prévention de la santé des pieds
merci d'être venu en plateau pour en
parler nous reprenons le cours de ce
journal avec un nouveau volet de notre
dossier consacré aux ivelinois présent
au Festival de Cannes sur place pour
Radio sensation et pour TVfil et Nicolas
kirilovitz après un échange hier avec un
jeune réalisateur de plaisir rencontre
ce soir avec un cinéphile de
basemont 200000 c'est le nombre de
personnes présente à Cannes pendant le
festival habituellement la ville ne
compte que 74000 habitants pour les
cinéphiles Cannes c'est le paradis
imaginez plutôt 83 long métrages seront
projetés cette année en sélection
officielle mais également pendant la
quinzaine des réalisateurs et la Semaine
de la Critique Jean y BO qui est un
passionné de cinéma originaire de
basemont il a relié les ivelines à Cann
en
vélo en général pour venir à canon prend
le train ou l'avion PAL des festivals
Jean y BO jeune retraité de 62 ans est
venu en vélo en 8 jours avec son vélo
assistance électrique et sa remorque il
a parcouru 1200 km et j'ai souffert un
peu de pluie simplement les deux
premiers jours mais ensuite ça s'est
relativement très bien déroulé y compris
même le vent dans la vallée du rô qui me
poussait berc donc en fait j'avais la
facilité de pouvoir descendre plus
facilement avec des vitesses
relativement tranquilles sans bien forcé
sans forcément mettre en plus
l'assistance électrique en fonction et
si Jean y fait le déplacement de
basemont à Cann pendant le festival
c'est bien pour le plaisir d'aller voir
des films rendez-vous au restaurant
jeanv est entouré de sa femme Martine et
de de leurs amis Catherine et Angel à
table il débrief les films qu'ils ont vu
et prépare le programme de la journée
belle histoire super images et cet
après-midi on va voir
donc tabasa un Indonésien ces passionnés
de cinéma se sont fixé un objectif aller
voir jusqu'à trois films par jour et
quand il s'agit de choisir les séances
jean-yve est plutôt du genre à se
reposer sur les filles les filles ont
travaillé sur le programme
là Mo j'étaisillé hier à 20h j'étais
piqué une tête dans l'eau on m'a même
demandé d'ailleurs d'ailleurs si l'eau
était froide je dit bah non même plutôt
chaude même à cet he là en fin de
journée participer au festival de Cann
jean-y savour sa chance voici le
précieux sésame ce badge qui lui permet
d'assister gratuitement aux séances pour
l'obtenir il a dû s'inscrire en début
d'année on écrit en fait une lre de
motivation à la direction fait du
festival de CAN qui elle en fait va nous
permettre d'obtenir alors il y a un
nombre assez conséquent de de sésam qui
est qui sont distribués à savoir 4000
4000 places donc ça laisse en fait
beaucoup de de possibilités pour tous
les canis et puis d'autres personnes en
fait d'être invité et d'avoir la
possibilité dans le cadre de can
cinéphile de pouvoir assister à toutes
ces toutes ces projections installer
confortablement dans son fauteuil Jean y
est maintenant prêt à être plongé dans
une nouvelle aventure c'est une
découverte et c'est surtout en fait
quelque chose qui est complètement
différent de la télévision puisque en
fait on a un grand écran on est dans une
salle sombre on a le son qui arrive de
tous les côtés et c'est en fait une
manière aussi de justement de de
s'inclure dans le film et puis de se
presque de se retrouver au travers de
l'écran c'est sincèrement un réel
plaisir de s'isoler là pendant pendant 2
he ou un peu moins de 2h sur la
projection pour pouvoir réellement
communier avec le film La lumière
s'éteint dans la salle place à la magie
du cinéma d'ici la fin du festival jean-
y Martine Angel et Catherine espèr avoir
vu jusqu'à 40 films 40 histoires et
autant de souvenirs et d'avis à partager
en rentrant
un rendez-vous à ne pas manquer
maintenant pour les amateurs de voile le
skipper Vincent rou vainqueur du vent
des globes en 2005 est à l'île de loisir
de saquentin en Eveline jusqu'à la fin
de la semaine avec son équipe le public
peut le rencontrer comme Michel ido et
William l pour
TVF une légende de la voie la l'île de
loisir de 50 Ansel vincentou célèbre
skipper vainqueur du vent des globes en
2004 et de la Transat JAC Vabre en 2013
va naviguer avec son équipe PRB jusqu'à
ce vendredi sur l'ÉTS un plan d'eau que
le marin a déjà dompté alors j'étais
venu sur la base au loisir de
Saint-Quentin il y a une trentaine
d'années faire une régate de derriveur
voilà c'est un endroit que je trouve un
petit peu hors du temps là ce ce point
de verdure et ce point d'eau en plein
milieu de de la ville je trouve que
c'est ouais c'est génial c'est vous
disposez de
ici de d'un site qui est qui est
vraiment fabuleux et qui permet de
découvrir les sports nautiques comme
plein de plan d'eau intérieur en France
la team PRB présente également
gratuitement au public de l'île de
loisirs son tout nouveau bolit des m
baptisé diam 24 un trimarin monotype
d'une longueur de 7 M25 m un bateau qui
participera au Tour de France à la voile
en juillet l'idée de de ce petit bateau
transportable qu'on peut amener partout
sur le littoral ou à l'intérieur des
terres c'est justement de faire des
régates des courses à la voile très très
proche du public et de pouvoir bah de
pouvoir amener un visuel vers le grand
public parce qu'en général on monte nos
bateaux au départ des courses à
l'arrivée des courses mais entre les
deux ben les gens ont pas ont pas
forcément la possibilité de de nous voir
évoluer parce que ben parce que voilà
les bateaux sont gros ils peuvent pas
s'approcher des côtes et puis parce que
Ben les les parcours le permettent pas
non plus si vous voulez observer
peut-être tester ce voilier rendez-vous
sur l'île de loisir le trimmaran jette
l'encre à quelques encablures du club de
voile de
Saint-Quentin un mot d'environnement
d'économie également avec ce marécher
bio installé à maniamo nous vous
l'avions déjà présenté dans ce journal
Robert pirz c'est son nom il vient de
livrer ses premiers client exemple d'une
reconversion réussie pour cet ancien
salarié de l'industrie avec Mélanie
poquet ils sont arrivés avec 15 jours
d'avance mais pour le plus grand plaisir
des amapiens Manis il ce sont les
légumes cultivés par Robert pirè le
nouveau marécher de Man c'est émouvant
il y a quelque chose de d'émouvant dans
dans cette dans cette première
distribution parce que les légumes sont
là parce qu'ils sont arrivés ils avait
même plusieurs semaines d'avance avec le
avec la chaleur et je suis très content
de pouvoir de pouvoir fournir un beau
panier pour pour cette première
distribution aux amapiens de manie et
chat il y a encore 4 ans Robert Pires
travaillait dans l'industrie depuis
quelques mois il s'occupe de 10 hectares
de terrain situé près du centrebourg de
manie pour sa première livraison il
amène salade radis ou encore Chourave ce
soir je vais servir des radiers à mes
enfants et je vais leur dire que ces
radis ont poussé sur la terre sur
laquelle on vit sur une terre manicoise
et et que c'est le même soleil qui les
fait grandir qui fait grandir aussi ses
radis ça correspond vraiment à un
aboutissement dans une philosophie de
consommation parce que je sais qu'en en
prenant les légumes de Robert bon je
soutiens en fait un emploi une activité
en maréchage de proximité en circuit
court j'ai un petit peu de mal à évaluer
en fait mercredi soir Robert piress a
fourni 19 paniers en attendant la
prochaine
livraison loisir et la 3e édition du
pique-nique géant organisé par la ville
de plaisir c'était le weekend dernier
moment convivial avec toute une série
d'animation nous y étions bonjour
bonjour Daniel son épouse et ses deux
enfants sont venus pour la deuxème fois
participer au piquenique géant organisé
par la me de plaisir la nappe était
distribuée par la ville ils ont apporté
les couverts et les victuailles c'est
super bien mais après comme je dis un
pecnique faut avoir le beau temps voilà
sans le beau temps ça gâche un peu tout
quoi vous allez rester toute
l'après-midi vous allez faire activités
oui oui parce que là on a des amis qui
vont nous rejoindre avec même un bébé et
tout on va faire les activités le petit
il a ramené les trottinettes les ballons
voilà si certains sont venus se détendre
sans contrainte d'autres se sont lancés
dans la collection des nappes de
l'événement à chaque édition une nappe
thématique de couleurs différentes est
offerte par la ville il y a 2 ans
c'était millésimes rouge avec des
question sur
lesécesponsabilité bleu c'était l'année
d'avant l'année d'après plutôt et puis
cette année c'est vert donc à la la méie
de plaisir donne distribue des nappes à
tous les Plaisirois ou à tous ceux qui
veulent venir au pique-nique afin de
pouvoir s'asseoir par terre et de
pouvoir profiter du moment cette année
deux animations ont été proposées aux
participants démonstration de Tai et de
pêche à la mouche un sport méconnu qui a
attiré bien des curieux il y a une
curiosité en fait parce que c'est vrai
que c'est c'est quand même très étonnant
d'arriver à lancer une mouche qui pèse
même pas 1 g à 20 30 ou 40 m pour les
meilleurs donc c'est
effectivement je comprends que ça puisse
attirer puis le geste est vraiment
particulier donc par rapport qui est
incomparable par rapport à toutes les
autres pêches cette manifestation lancée
il y a 4 ans à l'initiative de la
mairite de plaisir pour que les
habitants s'approprient leur patrimoine
fédère chaque année toujours un peu plus
on est à notre 4e édition de notre
piquenique géant donc une initiative à
l'origine de Madame le Maire qui a
souhaité faire redécouvrir le parc du
château au Plaisirois et leur rappeler
bah qu'il était libre disponible
accessible on estime hein c'est jamais
facile de compter mais à peu près 2000
personnes qui viennent en famille avec
les amis profiter donc de ce cadre
magnifique événement inaugurant le
programme des beaujours culturel de
plaisir celui-ci sera suivi notamment de
sorties cinéma et théâtre en plein air
pour se clôturer avec la nuit des
étoiles début
août et pour conclure cette édition le
weekend dernier toujours maises àis
d'Arcis c'est un salon dédié au
bien-être et à la beauté qui s'est tenu
baptisé arc féminin un salon et qui
était consacré à la mode femme et
enfants bijou cosmétique durant 2 jours
une dizaine de femmes chefs d'entreprise
pratiquant la vente à domicile étai
présente pour présenter et pour vendre
leur produits William
l vêtements accessoires et cosmétique à
l'approche de la fête des mères les
femmes étaient à l'honneur durant de
jours à bois d'Arc un salon pour le
bien-être mais aussi un moyen de faire
connaître la VDI la vente à domicile
indépendant la VDI c'est un secteur qui
est vraiment en pleine expansion en ce
moment on a ça nous tenait vraiment à
cœur pour notre ville de montrer
l'ensemble des entrepreneurs qui
représentai toute la ville de Bois
d'Arcy on a la chance également de se
faire connaître de faire un petit peu de
publicité de montrer de quoi on vit de
quoi on on est passionné une passion que
ces femmes exerce tous les jours au
domicile de leur clientes création vente
ou service ce weekend pour elle c'était
aussi l'occasion de rencontrer une
nouvelle clientèle le but c'est vraiment
de faire connaître à nos clientes et aux
visiteurs le fonctionnement de la v di
de faire connaître avant tout nos
produits mais également de reprendre des
rendez-vous à leur domicile pour que
elles aussi bénéficie de cadeaux de
réduction et pourquoi pas recruter avec
leur entourage leurs proches durant de
jours le salon n'a pas désempli environ
150 arcisiennes sont venus découvrir le
travail de ces entrepreneuses qui ont pu
remplir leur carnet d'adresse chacun a
son domaine chacun explique ses produits
enfin donc c'est c'est une bonne
connaissance des professionnels on
découvre des choses bah qu'on
connaissait déjà d'autres qu'on
connaissait moins je pense que le faire
travailler effectivement les les
auto-entrepreneuses de Bois d'Arcy ben
je trouve ça génial cet événement était
une première pour la ville de Bois
d'Arcy une opération réussi d'après les
organisatrices qui réfléchissent déjà à
une deuxè édition c'est la fin de ce
journal rendez-vous demain aux mêmes
horaires pour un nouveau point complet
sur l'actualité locale excellente
soirée